[Music]
music gets you through the morning run
it gets you through the drive to work
and maybe even the work itself
perhaps music also is getting you
through the pandemic for most of us it's
a reflex to find the songs that suit the
mood
but for a small group of local
therapists finding the right song means
much more
[Music]
we all use music therapeutically without
even
realizing it
this little life and the way that that
creates
you know a drum beat a bass line that
you know is the basis of everything
[Music]
little hazel's world moves at a
different pace she's surrounded by the
adoration of her parents
tubes and medicines and the relentless
sound of her ventilator keeping her tiny
heart alive
so hazel is our miracle baby
hazel was born with a brain disorder no
one knows how long she'll live
it's crucial to fill the time she has
with life
two and a half years later still kicking
bailey hinns helps change the rhythm
every few weeks she fills hazel's home
with therapy
she you know has defied the odds and
been a little miracle
sing for all your friends we all like to
hear you hinz is a board-certified music
therapist
one of the few in las vegas music can
help us to process those emotions
something that would create that sense
of peace
even if it didn't help her like it helps
me and it helps her dad just kind of
um it's therapeutic for us
therapy at the start of a challenging
life hello hello
and at the end of another this is amory
care assisted living
everyone who lives here has some form of
alzheimer's or dementia and a happy
new year got your feet going i like that
if you play music especially from their
past
they seriously come to life and it calms
them down it
makes them feel at peace peace that's
been hard to find in a pandemic
when many of hinz's most vulnerable
patients need it more than ever
i was unable to be in person with any of
my patients
with end of life specifically it was
it was very difficult to not be there
with someone
holding their hand and providing
that in person comfort made out of
gold her patients are fragile frequently
time is short
yeah sweet girl so she's doing something
a little different i continue to be
amazed by
just listening to the heartbeat hinz is
recording the music we carry
inside and making music hazel's parents
can cherish
forever it's something that is
meaningful to the family and they can
continue to
listen to this living breathing
person that they love long after
they are no longer with us
[Music]
it's just a song about love
and we love her our hearts
create music inherently they just do
it's bringing forth the the song that
i mean that's in in all of us
[Music]
if you are interested in music therapy
we have attached a link
to the state's website on this practice
we'll have a web story up in just a
little bit this morning
and it has information on it with links
to certified therapists in the valley
a big thank you to bailey for helping us
tell that story and the families in the
nursing home involved as well